all right tonight gas prices i mean this
is awful at horrific levels look at this
it's over six dollars a a
a gallon on average in southern
california just as donald trump
predicted wow now keep in mind that
doesn't mean just higher prices at the
pump that means higher prices to heat
and cool your home and for every product
you buy at every store you go to and as
the wall street journal put a quote this
trickles down to everything even your
potato salad and don't forget whatever
you buy is shipped in a truck they use
diesel and guess what much of it is made
in a factory or farm that now faces
rising energy costs and by the way look
at the price of fertilizer it's through
the roof by the way that
that price also was wrapped in plastic
oh that too is made with oil but
according to biden's energy secretary
jennifer granholm we just need to suck
it up because the the climate can't wait
she said
so she's basically shoving her middle
finger in the face of all of you every
single american saying f you climate
change is more important than your
financial life struggles and today
because of these failed policies
economic and energy well 64 of americans
right now are living paycheck to
paycheck and then we get a lecture
uh by this out of touch jackass that
doesn't know jack adam schiff about real
life and according to her a green energy
transformation could lead to peace in
our time uh
the entire administration is this
is this locked into this climate
alarmist religious cult watch
the climate is not going to wait on our
efforts to confront
autocrats both crises need addressing
now as minister
ryan has said this clean energy
transition
could be the peace project
of our time
but peace
always comes after struggle
so let's give this
peace project the focus and the
commitment and the resources
of a wartime effort
our
marshall plan
here with reaction former trump energy
secretary rick perry rick i would
imagine if you were still energy
secretary you wouldn't be doing a deal
with iran you wouldn't be begging opec
to produce more oil and you wouldn't be
considering importing oil from iran or
venezuela but i'm just guessing
a year and a year and a half ago we
wouldn't need to do any of those things
america was leading the world in the
production of energy
we were
doing what donald trump had asked us to
do
and we were making europe safer
uh we had the uh iranians on their knees
uh the
the chinese were paying attention to us
very respectfully i might add and russia
wasn't about to take on the united
states all of that changed
in a very short period of time sean um
and what the secretary of energy is
talking about here
uh yeah it's a piece of something all
right it's a piece of junk uh the idea
that you're going to bring america to
its knees
in this
effort to chase after
this issue of the climate when
they won't face the facts
american clean energy was reducing the
emissions in the world and we could
continue to be doing that
we could have been replacing indian coal
with american natural gas we could have
been replacing old
coal plants in europe with american
natural gas that would have been making
a real difference on the emissions not
to even mention
what could be happening out there
if the the administration would embrace
small modular reactors
so joe is willing to
joe's willing to allow a 40-year
inflation high just costing the average
family according to penn wharton
anywhere between 3 500 or 5 grand a year
the highest gas prices we've ever had uh
compromise on national security and
begged the world's uh worst countries uh
to do deals with us that's his policy
uh sean it's it's amazing to me
that we've got the answer right here in
front of us
these people are
you know it's like two uh uh kids and
and one of them just can't say i was
wrong
when the fact of the matter is everybody
knows they were wrong with their energy
policy they know that america has the
ability to not only stabilize the world
out there because of our abundance of
energy but we had the uh
we had the ability to go into europe we
had the ability to send a clear message
to russia is we're not going to put up
with your nonsense uh putin
and and he was paying attention at that
particular point in time because he knew
we had him
literally over a barrel so to speak and
this president let him up he's making
deals with the iranians then he goes and
begs
these countries that don't like us to
give us their fuel craziness we need you
back we need the adults back
uh governor secretary thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else